alors quoi de beau
alors quoi de beau allez c'est bon on y
va
[Musique]
elle est bonne la pêche
vous avez un objectif de points juste
pour le plaisir
comment on gagne chez vous là
chez moi on gagne à tous les coups non
il y a 250 lycées
ou pas
les gens alors que moi les gens ils
voient
ils ont peur faudra lui dire au clown il
y a pas de souci je vais lui faire une
formation comment tu vas choisir
[Musique]
moi je vais tirer le gros nounours rose
attends attends attends attends attends
attends
attends vous avez un ciseau
[Musique]
madame my innocente il me faut une main
innocente
un poisson
yes on a gagné merci
plaisir vous voulez jouer parce qu'il
vient de l'installer là je pense les
gagnants je suis le directeur
le roi de la pièce
merci Chef et il a pris sa pièce hein
[Rires]
bombarder OK
on a le droit de mettre des coups de
pied dans le truc pas moi
ok
parce que là vous vous amusez là
il est pas très cool aussi il est super
cool ah bon des fois il vient il enlève
lui-même
on peut lui demander pour celle-là aussi
on lui dit qu'on a beaucoup joué sur
celle-là ok quoi au go go go et là tu
triches encore là mais moi je pense
ouais
allez
[Musique]
salut lescends là tu as vu c'est bon
tricher sans tricher
alors un truc c'est touché la vie
[Musique]
c'est des liasse quoi c'est des liasses
viens on se casse en courant regarde
comment les riches regarde comment elle
est riche 25 pièces on sait jamais on
sait jamais ça se trouve on est à 25
pièces
allez là encore gagné encore gagné de
côté c'est une technique ça c'est une
technique la deuxième mi-temps
alors les joueurs les joueurs allez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et vous êtes capable de partir en
vacances ensemble après quoi
moi Saint-Tropez sympa on se refuse rien
là maintenant allez touche la
ah si on peut pas taper
là il triche là là il triche il les
avance ou il fait quoi là allez là
comme on est riche il y a plein de
moments il faut qu'on s'arrête aussi
parce que apparemment ça fait un à une
heure
allez
c'est fatiguant je vais avoir des
courbatures ça c'est une technique aussi
c'est la jambe là
elle est là
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire de tous cet
argent Daniel boulot
alors quoi de beau
[Musique]